bastien sébastien on avait dit pas dans
la chambre c'est pas du tout comment ils
sont arrivés
et où l'autre
passion qu'est ce que tu fais tu vas
être en retard à l'école tout chalet de
césar connaissent peut vous emmener je
voulais vous avez déjà regardé
chaussettes messieurs sauvegarde etc le
vide et la mort elle savait plus de
quatre ans que je cherche partout
machine qu'est ce qui prouve que vous
citiez d'olhain
michel soit personnes ils suivent ce
qu'ils aiment raccompagner chez eux
aussi
[Musique]
c'est ma faute je suis trop vieux c'est
moi qui trouve
pas se laisser faire on va aller les
chercher
parce que chez moi line ils penseront
jamais à nous chercher là bas
si ma chaîne a disparu je te jure vous
allez finir dans le ravin
je promis de protéger
si bien dire
toilettes humaine
l'épave ou bell sera jamais à vous auj
[Musique]